The
sickly sweet sugar water known as Coca-Cola
was initially marketed as a magical cure-all
tonic for every kind of “nervous affliction”
imaginable from headaches to hysteria- a condition
that, fun fact, used to be treated in women
through medically administered orgasms.
This ultimately led to the creation of vibrators
to help out the no doubt cramped handed doctors
who just didn’t have the stamina to keep
up with the countless hysterical women banging
on their doors…
(More on this in our article Why Women Fainted
So Much in the 19th Century)
Of course, as with so many new ventures, when
it first became available to the public on
May 8, 1886, Coca-Cola was a bit of a flop,
averaging only about 9 glasses per day sold
in the first year.
This was despite the fact that it debuted
at one of the most popular soda fountains
in Atlanta, Georgia, located in Jacob’s
Pharmacy.
For reference here, their gross earnings on
soda sales, according to the owner of the
pharmacy, Dr. Joseph Jacobs, was about $150
per day (or about $4,100 today), of which
Coca-Cola accounted for about 45 cents daily
in the first year.
This is mildly surprising considering not
only is Coca-Cola reasonably tasty, but it
was also, as mentioned, being marketed by
the medical professionals involved as a cure
for countless medical issues, including a
rather serious one in morphine addiction.
On top of that, they also pitched it as something
of the Viagra of its day…
(No doubt this effect on men is partially
how it was supposed to go about curing hysteria
in women…)
And if the marketing and flavour didn’t
work, their trump card was the fact that it
contained coca leaf extract, a.k.a. cocaine,
as well as lime juice which aids in cocaine
absorption in the stomach for maximal bang
for your buck on the drug element.
Seemingly this should have seen it become
a huge hit rather quickly, though it is noteworthy
that various cocaine products were widely
available at the time, so perhaps people didn’t
have need to come back to Coca-Cola to get
their fix.
Whatever the case, as to how its inventor,
pharmacist John Pemberton, came up with the
tonic, he was specifically looking for a cure
for his own morphine addiction.
You see, Pemberton was a former Confederate
soldier who nearly had his head lopped off
in the Battle of Columbus.
During his recovery from his wounds, as with
so many others at the time, he became addicted
to morphine and so was looking for something
to wean him off the habit.
This all led him to experimenting with coca-leaf
extract, and thus Pemberton’s French Wine
Coca was born, which he claimed did the trick.
(Though it should be noted that when he died
of stomach cancer two years later in 1888,
he was still addicted to morphine.)
Unfortunately for him, his initial concoction
also included alcohol (from wine), which became
banned in Atlanta where he lived in the same
year he debuted his tonic, resulting in him
substituting the wine with sugar and citric
acid.
He also, of course, mixed the whole thing
with carbonated water, owing to, at the time,
fizzy water being thought to be good for your
health.
Finally, in 1886 Pemberton was ready to start
selling what would eventually become arguably
the most famous non-water beverage brand on
Earth.
After a deal was struck with Dr. Joseph Jacobs
of the aforementioned Jacobs’ Pharmacy and
the soda fountain operator within, Willis
Venable, Coca-Cola finally graced the world
with its presence, selling for 5 cents per
serving (about $1.38 today).
Poor sales and a loan Venable had received
from Jacobs’ to build a house ultimately
saw Venable trade his 1/3 stake to Jacobs
in repayment of said cash advance.
As for Jacobs, he had little interest in producing
and marketing the drink and was generally
annoyed with having to deal with Pemberton
and his huge financial problems.
Thus, not long after he acquired Venable’s
share, he sold his entire stake in Coca-Cola
to fellow pharmacist Asa Candler, for, to
quote Jacobs “some stock in a glass factory
on South Pryor Street…
This factory, on which the insurance had been
allowed to lapse, was destroyed shortly afterward
by fire.
In addition to the stock I was to receive
some odds and ends such as bed pans, pewter
syringes, wooden pill boxes, and empty bottles.”
Candler, after buying out the remaining shares,
including from Pemberton, would start the
process that turned the brand into the beverage
powerhouse it is today, by 1919 himself selling
the brand and recipe for a cool $25 million
(about $361 million today) to a group of investors.
As for Pemberton, when he sold his stake to
Candler he did have a thought to leave a partial
share to his son, Charles, in the hopes the
morphine-addiction curing drink would someday
become a huge hit.
However, ultimately Charles and he opted to
just take as much money as they could get
at the time and forgo any further stake in
Coca-Cola.
Pemberton died shortly thereafter in poverty
and his son Charles followed him about six
years later, ironically dying of a morphine
overdose.
The name “Coca-Cola” was suggested by
Pemberton’s bookkeeper, Frank Robinson,
stemming from two of the key ingredients:
extracts from the coca leaf and kola nut.
Robinson was also the one to first pen the
now classic cursive “Coca-Cola” logo.
To fully replicate Coca-Cola, in the United
States at least, you’d need something only
one company has legal access to- unprocessed
coca leaves.
Currently, only Stepan Co. can import these
leaves into the United States.
They then process the leaves and sell the
cocaine-free extract to Coca-Cola and the
cocaine to the pharmaceutical company Mallinckrodt.
Thus, to make your own Coca-Cola with the
exact correct recipe, you’d need to convince
Stepan Co. to branch out and sell to your
company too.
This is likely a tall order considering the
pressure Coca-Cola would put on them not to.